after two years of quiet easter dinners
joanne thompson and alan white are
planning to spend this year visiting
family
it's very meaningful the last two years
we've all felt it it's really taken a
toll on the family bonds for sure in
most provinces masks are not required in
most settings gathering limits have been
lifted and physical distancing has all
but disappeared but covid has not
let me just emphasize all across canada
doesn't matter where you are it's very
likely
that omicron variant the ba2 sublineage
is
spreading quite widely in your community
i would advise getting that booster shot
and masking
and improving ventilation still dr
theresa thamps stopped short of
recommending provinces bring back mass
mandates something only quebec and pei
are keeping in place until after the
holidays on monday philadelphia brought
its mass mandates back anticipating
families will gather for passover and
easter it's the first major u.s city to
do so each individual is going to have
to make their calculation of the amount
of risk that they want to take for weeks
health experts have been recommending
the canadian government change the
definition of fully vaccinated to three
doses not two concerned our national
numbers have languished below 50 percent
for months
when i see people in the hospital and i
say how come you've only had
two doses that's because they say i
didn't know i was supposed to get a
third dose
and that's frustrating the change is
under review so for now the focus
remains on encouraging a third shot the
national advisory committee on
immunization now says everyone over 18
should get a booster and canadians 12 to
17 may be offered one six months after
their second dose some people also think
that well i just got an infection so
maybe i don't need a booster
we are recommending it urging canadians
to celebrate but with the expectation
they'll use the personal protective
measures at hand jamie morocco global
news toronto